Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. Today we're tackling one of the big beasts of historical arguments, the kind of subject that frankly is likely to get us cancelled. We're going to be talking about empire. What is empire? What's it for? Where's it come from? And can it ever be a good thing or is it always morally wrong
感谢收听《往事并不如烟》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《往事并不如烟》。今天我们要探讨的是历史争论中的庞然大物之一，这种话题坦率地说很可能会让我们遭到“封杀”。我们要谈论的是帝国。什么是帝国？帝国是用来做什么的？它从何而来？它有没有可能是件好事，还是说它在道德上永远是错误的？
tom holland i've been uh dreaming since we started of getting you cancelled and this is my chance um well so let's start by saying what we are going to talk about yeah of course we're talking about empires very broadly aren't we we're not going to be talking about a specific empire we're going to span the whole of history and the idea well i mean let's get down to what is an empire would you say well um let's let's go to the etymology let's say you know where does the word empire come from uh it comes from a latin word imperium and the meaning of imperium over the course of the roman empire changes in a quite interesting way. So imperium is it's a command, but it's also the right that someone has to issue a command.
汤姆·霍兰，自从我们开始做节目以来，我一直梦想着看你被封杀，这就是我的机会。嗯，好吧，那我们先说说我们要讨论的内容。是的，当然，我们要非常广泛地谈论帝国，对吧？我们不会讨论某个具体的帝国，而是要跨越整段历史。至于这个概念——我是说，让我们落实到到底什么是帝国，你会怎么说？嗯……让我们从词源说起，你知道，帝国的英文单词“empire”是从哪个词来的？它源自拉丁语“imperium”，而在罗马帝国时期，“imperium”的含义发生了一个相当有趣的转变。所以，“imperium”既是一个命令，同时也是某人发布命令的权力。
So an imperator. It's like authority almost. Yeah. So an imperator, conventionally translated as a general, is someone who has authority, who has power over the men who are subject to him um imperator becomes the title that augustus the first roman emperor gets and and our word emperor comes from imperator but and so it implies that he has imperium over a vast sway of of of the empire and of the people within it and it's during um aug Augustus's life that a great map of the empire goes up in the forum and that starts to that that's a kind of a symbol for the way in which the understanding of imperium changes to actually mean the physical territory that the Romans have power over. And I think that that sense of a physical
所以说，imperator（统帅）。这几乎就像是权威。是的。因此，统帅（imperator）传统上被翻译为将军，是指拥有权威、对受其支配的人享有权力的人。嗯，“imperator”后来成为了奥古斯都——第一位罗马皇帝的头衔，而我们英语中的皇帝（emperor）一词就源于“imperator”。因此，它暗示着他对帝国的大片疆域以及其中的人民拥有最高统治权（imperium）。正是在奥古斯都在世期间，论坛上竖起了一张帝国的宏大地图，而这开始成为一种象征，标志着人们对“imperium”的理解发生了变化，最终指代罗马人拥有统治权的实际领土。我认为这种实质性的
amount of territory, you know, in the Roman, classically, it's kind of subcontinental, it's a vast, vast array of territory, combined with authority, that one person, or perhaps, you know, a particular people have authority and power over other peoples. So I think that perhaps the two key elements of empire are that you have a centre, you have a dominant centre and you have peripheral. Yeah, you have a metropole and then you have peripheral regions. And also you have an idea that one, you know, that this metropolis, this metropole, this centre has authority and power over the peripheral regions. So I would guess that would be how I would describe empires. But Tom, could you not go, I mean, I don't want to play the whole fixture on away turf as it were. We should come further forward at some point, but couldn't you go further back
领土广度——你知道的，在经典的罗马概念中，它有点像次大陆的规模，是一片极其辽阔的领土，再加上一个人（或者某个特定民族）对其他人民拥有权威和权力。所以我想，帝国的两个核心要素可能在于：你拥有一个中心，一个占统治地位的中心，同时你还拥有边缘地区。是的，你拥有一个核心都市，然后是边缘地区。此外，你还有这样一种观念：这个大都会、这个核心都市、这个中心，对边缘地区拥有权威和权力。所以我想，我大概会这样来描述帝国。但是，汤姆，难道你就不能——我是说，我不想一直在客场作战，我们总得在某个时候把时间线推进到更近的时期——难道你就不能回溯得更远一点，
and say that the very first civilisations that we know of, let's say, you know, 5,000 years ago or whatever, the two kingdoms of Egypt, the Indus Valley, sort of Mesopotamia, Akkad and all these kind of places, that society itself originated often as empires. I mean, obviously, it didn't originate as nation states. Well, yeah. Sophisticated powers had elites that governed places with lots of different people who often
然后说，我们所知道的最早的文明，比方说，五千年前左右的埃及两个王国、印度河流域、美索不达米亚的阿卡德以及所有这些地方，社会本身往往就是作为帝国起源的？我的意思是，它们显然不是作为民族国家起源的。好吧，是的。成熟的政权拥有精英阶层，这些精英统治着许多不同的人群，而这些人往往
spoke different dialects or languages, or maybe worshipped different gods, and that they had a single authority. I mean, obviously obviously persia is the is the famous example of that isn't it which you've written about well there's this fantastic phrase imperio genesis the process by which empires come to be formed and you talked about egypt and you talked about mesopotamia um in egypt the figure of the pharaoh he's a figure within in the roman sense imperium he has power but he also has comes to have authority over the entire nile valley that comes to constitute the kingdom of egypt and um everyone who lives along the nile they speak the same language they essentially worship the same gods they acknowledge
说不同的方言或语言，或者崇拜不同的神明，并且他们服从于单一的权威。我的意思是，波斯显然就是这方面的著名例子，不是吗？你对此写过文章。嗯，这里有一个极好的词——“帝国起源”（imperiogenesis），也就是帝国得以形成的过程。你谈到了埃及，也谈到了美索不达米亚。在埃及，法老这个人物，他在罗马的意义上就体现了“imperium”：他拥有权力，但他也逐渐对整个尼罗河流域拥有了权威，正是这片流域构成了埃及王国。而且，所有居住在尼罗河沿岸的人，他们说同样的语言，基本上崇拜同样的神明，承认
the same ruler um and so in a i i guess that um ancient egypt approximates perhaps more closely to our sense of a nation state. In Mesopotamia you have different cities and each city has to build walls essentially because to keep the wealth within and to keep outsiders outside and Mesopotamia on top of that has to deal with the fact that beyond the flood plains of the Tigris and the Euphrates, you have predatory powers lurking in the mountains, perhaps lurking in the deserts, who would, you know, if they had the chance, would come and grab a bit of this. So you cannot survive as a city-state in Mesopotamia unless you have a degree of militarism. And this militarism, in turn, inevitably fosters an ambition. Famously, the first person to do it, it supposedly is this guy sargon of the city
同一个统治者。所以我想，古埃及或许更接近我们对民族国家的理解。而在美索不达米亚，你拥有不同的城市，每座城市基本上都必须修建城墙，因为要把财富留在城内，把外人挡在城外。除此之外，美索不达米亚还必须面对这样一个现实：在底格里斯河和幼发拉底河的冲积平原之外，潜伏着盘踞在山地里、或许也潜伏在沙漠里的掠夺成性的势力，他们一旦有机会，就会跑来掠夺这里的一部分。因此，在美索不达米亚，除非你具备一定程度的军国主义，否则你根本无法作为一个城邦生存下来。而这种军国主义，反过来又不可避免地助长了一种野心。众所周知，第一个这么做的人，据说就是来自阿卡德城的这个家伙——
of akkad who conquered starts to conquer other cities and so it's the tradition of imperialism in the the middle east really i think that is the kind of the great granddaddy of what today we would think of as empires because um what begins with akkad goes on to you you get Assyria you get Babylon Assyria is a famously brutal and predatory empire and essentially its rule is founded on military oppression and on terror so when the Assyrians conquer a rival people they They will deport them. Famously, they do this to the 10 tribes of Israel. And in time, over the course of the Assyrian Empire, people who are deported to Assyria come to be called booty. So they are, you know, part of the loot that the Assyrians are carrying off. Those who resist are kind of ritually and humiliatingly killed. People are, you know,
萨尔贡，他开始征服其他城市。因此，中东的帝国主义传统，我认为它确实可以说是我们今天所理解的帝国的“始祖”；因为从阿卡德开始，接下来你会经历亚述、巴比伦。亚述是一个出了名的残酷且具有掠夺性的帝国，其统治基本上建立在军事压迫和恐怖之上。因此，当亚述人征服一个敌对民族时，他们会将其流放。最著名的是，他们对以色列的十个部落做了这件事。随着时间的推移，在亚述帝国期间，被流放到亚述的人们逐渐被称为“战利品”。所以他们，你知道的，成了亚述人掠夺的财物的一部分。那些反抗的人会被进行充满仪式感且奇耻大辱般的处死。人们，你知道的，
leaders are transported back, put in cages with wild animals outside the cities of Assyria so that people can watch them. Other people, you know, the kings have their heads cut off, their families will have their heads cut off, courtiers will be brought back to Nineveh, made to parade through the streets with heads round their necks. So these are spectacles of dread and terror. Assyria ends up basically being wiped from the face of the earth. Nineveh gets trampled down. And the reason for that is that terror and dread in the long run is insufficient to keep an empire. And the great empire that emerges, which expands far beyond Mesopotamia to rule Egypt and all the way to the Indus, is, as you said, the Persian Empire.
领袖们会被押送回来，关在亚述城市外的野生动物笼子里，供人们围观。其他人，你知道的，国王的头会被砍掉，他们家人的头会被砍掉，朝臣们会被带回尼尼微，被迫脖子上挂着人头在街头游行。因此，这些都是恐惧和恐怖的奇观。亚述最终基本上从地球上被抹去了。尼尼微被夷为平地。而原因就在于，从长远来看，恐怖和畏惧不足以维持一个帝国。正如你所说，那个崛起并远远超越美索不达米亚、统治了埃及一直延伸到印度河流域的伟大帝国，就是波斯帝国。
And the great thing that the Persians innovate is that they identify their empire with moral virtue. Their empire is a force for truth, is a force for light, is a force for goodness. And by defining their empire in that sense, it immediately means that those who oppose them are on the side of darkness and the lie. But, so, Tom, I mean, you obviously emphasised violence. And I guess a lot of, you know, 21st century scholars and people who sort of think about empire, think of empires in terms of violence and power and all this sort of oppression, I suppose. But there is obviously another way to think about this, which is that, let's say Persia, you give the example of Persia.
波斯人开创的伟大之处在于，他们将自己的帝国与道德美德画上等号。他们的帝国是真理的力量，是光明力量，是善良的力量。通过这种意义来定义他们的帝国，就直接意味着那些反对他们的人站在了黑暗和谎言的一边。但是，汤姆，我的意思是，你显然强调了暴力。我想21世纪的许多学者以及那些思考帝国的人，倾向于从暴力、权力和所有这类压迫的角度来看待帝国，我猜是这样的。但显然还有另一种思考方式，那就是，比方说波斯，你举了波斯的例子。
I know you've written about this in your book, Persian Fire. So the Persians have, you know, this amazing network of roads. They've got weights and measures. They've got a currency. They've got a currency they've got a sense of you know they view their own world as this kind of walled garden don't they and beyond is kind of barbarism and and savagery and within it all is order and presumably you could make an argument that if you're a sort of you you know, Joe Bloggs from media or from, you know, Mesopotamia or what's now Iran,
我知道你在你的书《波斯之火》中写过这一点。所以波斯人拥有，你知道的，这个惊人的道路网络。他们有度量衡。他们有货币。他们有一种观念，你知道的，他们将自己的世界视为某种“围墙花园”，对吧？而外界则是某种野蛮和未化之状态，在花园内部则是一切井然有序。据此，你可以提出这样一个论点：如果你是美索不达米亚或者现今伊朗地区的某个普通老百姓，
you might think, well, you know, life isn't actually so bad in the heart of this empire. We've got all this infrastructure. We've got all this stuff. Of course, there is always the ubiquitous threat that I might get my head cut off or whatever, but I'd rather that than live in an anarchic world of sort of savage clans fighting each other all the time
你可能会想，好吧，其实在这个帝国的核心地带，生活也并没有那么糟。我们拥有了所有的基础设施。我们拥有了这一切。当然，永远存在着一种无处不在的威胁，即我可能会被砍头或遭遇不测，但我宁愿承受这个，也不愿生活在一个无政府的世界里——生活在充满野蛮部族无休止厮杀、
and invaders coming and going and a sort of Hobbesian struggle for existence. I mean, that's the justification for empire through history, isn't it? That it equates to order. Well, I suppose that the Near East has basically always been ruled by empires, pretty much from the time of Sargon of Akkad. And the earliest experience of empire by and large is terrible. And the famous, I mean, seismically influential articulation of this is what we call the Old Testament. Because the Israelites and then the people of Judah, the southern kingdom, are, you know, they're tiny're tiny they're small they're minnows
侵略者不断来去的霍布斯式的生存斗争中。我的意思是，这就是历史上对帝国的辩护，不是吗？即帝国等同于秩序。嗯，我想近东基本上一直都是由帝国统治的，几乎从阿卡德人萨尔贡的时代起就是如此。而且人们对帝国的早期体验大体上是可怕的。对此，一个举世闻名且具有深远影响的表达就是我们所说的《旧金山圣经》（应为《旧约》）。因为以色列人，然后是犹大王国的人民，他们非常、非常渺小，他们是小民，
and so they're always being trampled down by the big powers by the Egyptians by the Babylonians by the Assyrians um and pharaohs and kings of Assyria in the old testament are are sinister figures um there is one exception that proves and this exception is cyrus who is hailed by isaiah as the messiah as the anointed one god's agent because that's cyrus the great cyrus the great what cyrus does is to say to the deported peoples who've been carried to mesopotamia you can go back home and among those are the people who will become the Jews who go back, you know, they've been weeping by the rivers of Babylon, they go back to Jerusalem, and they refound it. And so the Persians in the biblical tradition are remembered as good guys. And
所以他们总是被大国践踏——被埃及人、巴比伦人、亚述人践踏。在《旧约》中，法老和亚述国王都是阴险的人物。不过有一个例外证明了这一点，这个例外就是居鲁士。他被《以赛亚书》尊为弥赛亚、受膏者、上帝的代理人，因为他就是居鲁士大帝。居鲁士大帝做的事情是，对那些被流放到美索不达米亚的被遣返人民说：“你们可以回家了。”在这群人中，就包括那些后来成为犹太人的人。他们回去了，你知道的，他们曾在巴比伦河畔哭泣，如今他们回到了耶路撒冷，并重建了它。因此，在圣经传统中，波斯人被当作好人来铭记。而且，
absolutely, they, you know, for the people who become the Jews, the Persians are remembered very, very fondly, because basically, they, you because basically they provide peace, they provide order, they allow the people of Jerusalem to rebuild the temple. But isn't that how a lot of people living in the Persian Empire would have thought of Persia? So, for example, the classic thing, we talked in previous podcasts about Alexander the Great. Alexander the Great invades Persia
绝对地，对于那些成为犹太人的人来说，波斯人被非常、非常深情地铭记，因为基本上，他们提供了和平，他们提供了秩序，他们允许耶路撒冷的人民重建圣殿。但这难道不是生活在波斯帝国境内的许多人对波斯的看法吗？比如说，经典的事情是，我们在之前的播客中谈到过亚历山大大帝。亚历山大大帝入侵波斯，
and he says he's coming as a liberator and a hero. And his story in the West is always told of this intrepid adventurer who goes into this sort of evil empire and cuts the suede through it. But presumably if you're, you know, Joe Bloggs living in Persia and this Macedonian turns up with his army and says, I'm going to tear down your empire, I'm coming as a liberator. I mean, it's a nightmare, isn't it? These people kind of who don't speak your language, kind of charging through your country, smashing everything up. Presumably a lot of people quite like living in the Persian Empire. Yes. And the roots of Greek rule are much more shallow. of the reason why um the eastern mediterranean ends up greek speaking through vast swathes across
他说他是作为解放者和英雄而来的。他在西方的故事总是被讲述为一个无畏的冒险家，深入这个邪恶的帝国并从中杀出一条血路。但据此推测，如果你是生活在波斯的一个普通老百姓，而这个马其顿人带着军队出现，并宣称“我要拆毁你们的帝国，我是作为解放者而来的”，我的意思是，这简直是一场噩梦，不是吗？这些人说着你听不懂的语言，在你的国家横冲直撞，把一切都砸个粉碎。想必很多人其实很喜欢生活在波斯帝国里。是的。而且希腊统治的根基要浅得多。东地中海之所以在广阔的地域内——在希腊之外的广阔地域内——最终都开始说希腊语，
vast swathes beyond greece is that um what the greeks bring to the imperial tradition is the kind of the glamour and sophistication of their culture so that's another way in which um imperial powers can kind of really cement their rule is if the culture that they bring is sufficiently kind of appealing that I guess initially elites and then perhaps it kind of percolates down through the various classes that they come to identify with it and that's essentially how and why Greek ends up being spoken across the Eastern Mediterranean. And it's the same kind of process that ultimately happens with Rome, that although Rome is an unspeakably brutally militaristic power, I mean, it's militaristic in a way that kind of rivals the Assyrians, really. ultimately the reason that the Roman Empire coheres for as long as it does is because it is able to sell the idea of Romanitas of being Roman to the degree that
部分原因在于希腊人带给帝国传统的，是他们文化的光彩与精致。因此，这也是帝国力量巩固其统治的另一种方式：如果他们带来的文化具有足够的吸引力，我猜最初是精英阶层，然后这种文化可能会渗透到不同的阶层中，让他们开始认同这种文化。这基本上就是希腊语最终在整个东地中海被广泛使用的原因和过程。这也是罗马最终经历的同类过程。尽管罗马是一个无法形容的、极其残暴的军国主义政权——我的意思是，它的军国主义程度甚至真的能与亚述人媲美——但最终，罗马帝国之所以能凝聚如此之久，是因为它能够将“罗马性”（Romanitas，即作为罗马人的身份认同）这一理念兜售出去，以至于到
beginning of the third century all male adults across the empire are given citizenship and even when the Roman Empire in the West falls, people in the eastern half, what we call Byzantium, are still identifying themselves as Romans. And when the Ottomans turn up in 1453, the people who are defending Constantinople think of themselves as Romans, even though originally the people in the East had been conquered very, very brutally by Roman armies. And really, the surest way that an empire can survive and put down roots is to get the conquered people to feel that their the conquest has been for their own good no but doesn't that then raise the question of the alternatives to empire
了公元三世纪初，帝国境内的所有成年男性都获得了公民权。甚至当西罗马帝国灭亡时，东半部分（也就是我们所说的拜占庭）的人民仍然将自己认同为罗马人。当奥斯曼人在1453年兵临城下时，那些保卫君士坦丁堡的人依然认为自己是罗马人，尽管东方的人民最初曾遭到罗马军队极其残酷的征服。实际上，一个帝国能够生存并扎根的最稳妥的方式，就是让被征服的人民觉得，他们的征服是为了他们自己的好。但是，难道这不会引发关于帝国的替代方案的问题吗？
so if you're not living in an empire for most of human history, what are you living in? Well, in a sense, for most of Eurasian history, you have the great land empires. For most of Eurasian history, if you don't live in an empire, you're a barbarian. You're on the fringes. So you're on, you know, you're on beyond China, beyond Rome, beyond Persia, beyond the great empires of northern India.
因此，如果你在人类历史的大部分时间里并非生活在帝国中，那么你生活在什么里面？嗯，从某种意义上说，在欧亚大陆历史的大部分时间里，你生活在巨大的陆地帝国中。在欧亚大陆历史的大部分时间里，如果你不生活在帝国里，你就是一个野蛮人。你身处边缘。所以你身处——你知道的——中国之外、罗马之外、波斯之外、北印度的各大帝国之外。
So you're a nomad? You're a nomad, yes. And there's a sense in which empires come to define themselves against these nomads, against these barbarians. And that beds down the assumption that to live in a great empire is the kind of normal condition for humans. Now, in a sense, Europe is unusual in that after the Roman Empire implodes, it doesn't reconstitute itself. We did we did, you know, the episode on China where we were talking about, you know, is China one continuous empire?
所以你是个游牧民？你是个游牧民，是的。从某种意义上说，帝国正是通过将自身与这些游牧民、这些野蛮人作对比来定义自己的。这巩固了一种假设，即生活在一个伟大的帝国中是人类的常态。现在，从某种意义上说，欧洲是不寻常的，因为在罗马帝国崩溃之后，它并没有自我重组。我们做过——你知道的——关于中国的单集节目，当时我们在讨论：中国是一个连续不断的帝国吗？
Is it a sequence? I mean, it's a sequence of empires? And really it's both. But that idea of a Chinese empire as being the natural state of things is something that, you know, kind of splinters and that I think is a kind of crucial influence on the way that that we today in the West view empire because although we might be tempted to you know I think I think that there is a kind of sense very widespread that assumes that empire is basically synonymous with European colonialism but actually that's not the case at all what's distinctive about europe is precisely that empire has been a kind of very fleeting experience and that within the continent of western europe you know within western europe itself every attempt to reconstitute the roman empire has basically failed well i agree with that tom and i wonder whether, you see, what always strikes me when we talk about empires is this sense that the nation state is the norm. That's the assumption
它是一个序列吗？我的意思是，它是一系列帝国吗？实际上两者都是。但是，将中国帝国视为自然状态的那种观念，在某种程度上发生了分裂，我认为这对我们今天西方人看待帝国的方式产生了至关重要的影响。因为尽管我们可能倾向于——你知道，我认为——有一种非常普遍的看法，认为帝国基本上等同于欧洲殖民主义，但事实根本并非如此。欧洲的独特性恰恰在于，帝国一直是一种非常短暂的经历，并且在西欧大陆内部——你知道的，在西欧本身内部——每一次重建罗马帝国的尝试基本上都失败了。嗯，我同意这一点，汤姆。我不知道你是否发现，每当我们谈论帝国时，总是让我感到震惊的是那种将民族国家视为常态的观念。这种假设
now. That's what all 21st century sort of, all the discussion on social media or when people talk about it, they sort of say, why can't you leave people to govern their own affairs? Why can't they? But obviously, for most of human history, that was was not an option the nation state was not on the table as a as an alternative and most people would not have recognized it that way right so you talk about the roman empire when the roman empire fell um people didn't think to themselves oh brilliant we can have spain now we can live in you know know, we can live in Belgium. What they actually thought was that the fabric of order, the infrastructure on which we depended for trade, for exchange, for kind of promotion, for status, you know, for law and order is gone. And what is left is anarchy.
已经成了理所当然。这就是21世纪的所有讨论、社交媒体上的所有讨论或人们谈论它时的视角：他们会说，为什么不能让人们自己管理自己的事务？为什么他们不能？但显然，在人类历史的大部分时间里，那并不是一种选择。民族国家并没有作为一种替代方案摆在桌面上，大多数人也不会那样去认识它，对吧？所以你谈到了罗马帝国，当罗马帝国灭亡时，人们并没有对自己说：“太棒了，我们现在可以拥有西班牙了，我们可以生活在——你知道的，我们可以生活在比利时了。”他们实际上的想法是：维持秩序的体制、我们赖以进行贸易、交流、晋升、获取地位以及维护法律与秩序的基础设施已经不复存在了。剩下的只有无政府状态。
Well, no, I think that there were plenty of people who welcomed the collapse of Roman power, because I think by the end it had become incredibly... But they fancied power themselves, surely? That's true for the invaders, for the Franks and the Visigoths who take over the commanding heights of the imperial system. But I think for people lower down the social classes, I think that the collapse of Roman rule was often a liberation, because it meant that you weren't being oppressed by tax collectors. And by the end of the Roman Empire
哦，不，我认为有很多人其实欢迎罗马权力的崩溃，因为我认为到了最后，它已经变得极其……但他们自己也渴望权力，不是吗？对于侵略者来说确实如此，比如那些接管帝国系统最高指挥权的法兰克人和西哥特人。但我想对于社会底层的人民来说，罗马统治的崩溃往往是一种解放，因为这意味着你不再受到收税员的压迫。到了罗马帝国
in the West, it's become a hugely oppressive structure, because it depended on leeching vast amounts of money for taxes to pay for the military to keep it going. So the whole thing had become a kind of violently oppressive protection racket. Yeah, but surely there's a counter argument, which is that there's lots of people who are, I mean, there are sources that lament the death of the Roman Empire and that sort of say, oh, now we have to put up with, you know,
在西方的末期，它已经变成了一个极其压迫性的结构，因为它依赖于榨取巨额税收来维持军队的运转以维持自身。所以整个事情已经变成了一种通过暴力实施压迫的保护敲诈勒索集团。是的，但肯定还有另一种反论，那就是有很多人——我的意思是，有史料哀叹罗马帝国的灭亡，并说：“哦，现在我们不得不忍受——
tens of thousands of, you know, vandals or Visigoths or whatever roaming across the countryside, you know, who are presumed, I mean, I'm sure they're not kind of, you know, borrowing jugs of milk and paying for them afterwards. Absolutely.
成千上万的汪达尔人或西哥特人或其他什么人漫游在乡间，他们被假定为——我确信他们绝不是那种借了牛奶罐事后还会付钱的人。绝对是的。
You know know the empire is kind of held together by sinews and when those sinews get cut everything falls to pieces and and trade basically does start to to collapse although it's far more protracted than the kind of stereotype of the roman empire goes out and everything turns to darkness would would convey um but i think that yes i mean you're pointing, you know, what would people rather have? Would they rather have liberty or would they rather have anarchy?
你知道的，帝国是靠筋脉维系在一起的，而当这些筋脉被切断时，一切都会四分五裂。贸易基本上也开始崩溃，尽管这比“罗马帝国一倒闭，一切都陷入黑暗”这种刻板印象所传达的要漫长得多。不过我认为，是的，你的确指出了这一点：人们更愿意选择什么？他们是愿意选择自由，还是愿意选择无政府状态？
And that's the way that in the Western tradition, it's often been framed. Because I think that we are, you know, in the West, we're the heirs to two great traditions. We're the heir to, you know, we have the heirs to two great traditions um we're the air to you know we have the bible and in the bible empires are generally regarded as the baddies so we've talked about how the egypt you know pharaoh is a is the oppressor of the children of israel um the assyrians and the babylonians um you know they they destroy the kingdom of israel they destroy the kingdom of
这正是西方传统中经常用来建构这一问题的方式。因为我认为，我们在西方，是两大伟大传统的继承者。我们是——你知道的，我们是两大伟大传统的继承者。我们继承了——你知道的，我们有《圣经》。而在《圣经》中，帝国通常被视为坏蛋。所以我们讨论过埃及——你知道，法老是压迫以色列儿女的压迫者；亚述人和巴比伦人——
judah these are idle that's because they don't have an empire it's because they don't have an empire of their own yeah they're small yeah yeah but but it means that that those scriptures are powerful influence on our assumption that there is something morally corrupt with empire and then in the new testament you know jesus is tortured to death by the apparatus of a great imperial power and in the book of revelation i mean it's one i think it's the most influential work of anti-imperial propaganda ever written. The Whore of Babylon is an emblem of power to this day. You know, you have, you know, Rastafarians will talk about Babylon, London, New York, the the rest of the world is an incredibly powerful image of Roman imperialism and is one that we still kind of are the heirs of to this day. But we're also the heirs to Rome itself though Tom aren't we because I mean we talked in the previous episode about America and Rome I mean we surround the British Empire the great European empires they
你知道的，他们摧毁了以色列王国，他们摧毁了犹大王国。这些都是偶像——那是因为他们没有帝国，那是因为他们没有自己的帝国，对吧？他们很小，对吧？但这意味着，这些经文对我们的假设产生了强烈的影晌，让我们觉得帝国在道德上存在某种腐败。然后在新约中，你知道的，耶稣被一个伟大帝国机器折磨致死；而在《启示录》中——我的意思是，我认为这是有史以来最具影响力的反帝国宣传作品。直到今天，巴比伦大淫妇依然是强权的一个象征。你看，你知道的，拉斯塔法里教徒会谈论巴比伦、伦敦、纽约，世界上其余地方都是罗马帝国主义的一个极其强大的象征，并且这种象征至今仍深深影响着我们。但汤姆，我们也是罗马本身的继承者，不是吗？因为——我的意思是，我们在上一集中谈到了美国和罗马，我的意思是，我们周围的大英帝国、伟大的欧洲帝国，它们
modelled themselves on Rome to some extent. So we sort of have a dual inheritance. Would you agree with that? But even that classical inheritance is ambivalent because, of course, you're right that the example of Rome is absolutely enormous. I mean, when we think of empire, that's what we think of. And European powers traditionally, when they've aspired to empire, have modelled themselves on Rome. Absolutely. But there is an ambivalence in that classical tradition. Because if we're the heirs of Greece, the great heroic conflict for the Greeks was their battle against the Persian Empire.
在某种程度上都以罗马为模板。所以我们拥有双重继承。你同意吗？但即便这种古典继承也是矛盾的。因为，当然，你说得对，罗马的例子是无比巨大的。我的意思是，当我们想到帝国时，我们想到的就是罗马。而欧洲列强在传统上向往帝国时，都是以罗马为模板的。绝对是这样。但这其中存在着一种古典传统的矛盾。因为如果我们是希腊人的继承者，希腊人那场伟大的英雄式冲突就是他们对抗波斯帝国的战争。
When the Persians sought to expand westwards into Greece. And the battles of Marathon, the battles of Salamis. This was cast by the greeks as battles for freedom and at the end of the book about this yeah someone should and and 479 the great land battle of pletia when the armed invasion of greece is ended um the spartan uh commander goes to the great tent of the king that's been left for the Persian general. He's been killed, left dead on the battlefield of Plataea. And he goes in and he marvels at the wealth of gold and robes and everything.
当波斯人试图向西扩张进入希腊时，马拉松战役、萨拉米斯战役，被希腊人描绘为争取自由的战役。而在关于这场战争的著作的结尾——是的，有人应该这样说——在公元前479年的普拉提亚伟大陆战中，当对希腊的武装入侵结束时，斯巴达指挥官走进了波斯国王留给波斯将领的巨大帐篷。波斯将领已经在普拉提亚的战场上阵亡了。他走了进去，对那里的黄金财富、长袍和一切赞叹不已。
And he looks at this huge feast and he orders the Persian chefs to rustle up an enormous feast. And then he brings out the kind of traditional Spartan meal of disgusting broth. And he invites all the other Greek commanders in and says, look at this. Isn't this ridiculous? These Persians have come all this way to rob us of our poverty. And that's how the Greeks like to see themselves. As noble, as poor, as standing firm against imperialism. And that also is a part of our inheritance.
他看着这场盛宴，命令波斯厨师准备一顿丰盛的大餐。然后他拿出了斯巴达传统的令人作呕的肉汤餐，并邀请所有其他的希腊指挥官进来，说道：“看看这个。这不是很荒谬吗？这些波斯人长途跋涉来到这里，居然是为了剥夺我们的贫穷。”这就是希腊人喜欢看待自己的方式：高贵、贫穷、坚定不移地抵抗帝国主义。这也是我们遗产的一部分。
But let me jump in there, Tom. The Greeks had colonies. The Greeks established colonies in Sicily and, I don't know, southern Italy. They were colonisers themselves. So the idea of them as the sort of, you know, the rebel alliance of Star Wars, as these sort of noble, plucky Spartan freedom fighters, that surely doesn't hold water. The Greeks would have been perfectly happy to be imperialists they just weren't very good at it well and the Athenians and the Spartans in the
但让我插句话，汤姆。希腊人有殖民地。希腊人在西西里岛以及——我不知道——意大利南部建立了殖民地。他们自己就是殖民者。所以，把他们视为《星球大战》里的叛军同盟、视为那种高贵而勇敢的斯巴达自由斗士的这种观点，显然是站不住脚的。希腊人如果能成为帝国主义者会非常高兴的，他们只是不太擅长罢了。嗯，在波斯人被击败之后，雅典人和斯巴达人都尝试过建立帝国。我的意思是，雅典人基本上接管了波斯爱琴海帝国，没错，所以这里面有很大一部分伪善的成分，
wake of the uh the the defeat of the Persians both have a go at empire I mean the Athenians basically take over the Persian Aegean empire and right so yeah there's a massive kind of streak of hypocrisy there um completely and there's a street and there's the same strain in rome as well because for the romans um they likewise lay a great emphasis on on libertas on on freedom uh on the the way in which um turnip turnip eating peasantry is kind of the essence of roman virtue and that to rule an empire is to be corrupting. So by the time that the Romans are kind of invading Scotland, you have senators like Tacitus, who are seeing the whole kind of apparatus of empire as inherently corrupting. And so he's putting words into the barbarians who are opposing the Romans.
完全是这样。而且罗马也有同样的倾向。因为对于罗马人来说，他们同样非常强调“自由”（libertas）、强调这种纯朴的、靠吃芜菁为生的农民阶层才是罗马美德的精粹，并认为统治一个帝国会带来腐败。因此，当罗马人入侵苏格兰时，像塔西陀这样的元老就已经将帝国的整套机器视为本质上具有腐败性的了。于是他把这样的话借给那些抵抗罗马人的野蛮人之口。
And he gives to a Scottish chief in the famous line that they, you know, they create a desert and call it peace. that also in an accent I'm not gonna I'm not gonna risk turning off but but and but so that that's that also that Roman suspicion of empire is also a part of the cocktail that that we in the West inherit so we absolutely inherit that little Englanderism isn't that little Englanderism? Yeah, to a degree. But I mean, you know, it's the idea that empire is morally corrupting is something that we get from the Romans.
他借用了一句著名的苏格兰首领的名言，大意是他们创造了一片荒漠，却称之为和平。（而且我也不会冒着翻车的风险去模仿那种口音）。但是，这种罗马对帝国的怀疑，也是我们西方人所继承的鸡尾酒式传统的一部分。所以我们绝对继承了那种“小英国主义”，难道那不是小英国主义吗？是的，在某种程度上。但我的意思是，这种认为帝国在道德上具有腐败性的观点，是我们从罗马人那里继承的。
The idea that liberty is something worth fighting against enormous empires is something we get from the Greeks. And the idea that empires are morally corrupt is something that we get from the Bible. And that, you know, that is basically why the impulse to decolonize is incredibly western and so okay on that note on that note i'm going to stop you
这种认为自由是值得与庞大帝国抗争的观念，是我们从希腊人那里继承的。而这种认为帝国在道德上是腐败的观念，则是我们从《圣经》中继承的。这——你知道的——基本上就是为什么去殖民化的冲动具有极其浓厚的西方色彩的原因。所以，好吧，就冲这一点，我要阻止你
talking enough of tom holland's moral corruption we are going to take a short break and brew that perfect embodiment of empire a cup of tea and we should be back with mr corrupt after the break goodbye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment She'll be back with Mr Corrupt after the break. Goodbye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
继续说下去了。霍兰德先生的道德腐败就到此为止。我们要休息一会儿，去泡一杯堪称帝国终极化身的茶，休息过后，我们再回来见“腐败先生”。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐往事》。休息过后，我们再回来见“腐败先生”。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐往事》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一剂好莱坞八卦。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Last Thursday, we brought you the fabulously outrageous subject
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，向你展示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的收听体验、独家加更节目以及抢先获得现场门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《往事并不如烟》。上周四，我们为你带来了关于18和19世纪城市中性爱的精彩而离奇的话题，而本周四，我们将深入探究大熔炉，审视女巫和巫术在英国社会乃至欧洲社会中的角色。现在，我们要深入探讨一些关于帝国的问题。但在我们开始之前，汤姆，你还没有真正回答那个最大的问题，那就是：帝国总是坏事吗？不，因为帝国往往会制定出评判它们自身的标准。所以，我以前听你
of sex in the 18th and 19th century cities. And this Thursday, we're looking inside the cauldron and we're examining the role of witches and witchcraft in British society and indeed European society. And now we're going to get into some of these questions about empire. But before we do, Tom, you haven't really answered the big question, which is, is empire always bad? No, because empires tend to create the standards by which they're judged so i've heard
说过这个。我总觉得这太闪烁其词了。嗯，这方面的经典例子就是阿拉伯帝国——对吧？那个帝国难道不是吗？好吧，所以阿拉伯人提出了这一主张——所以阿拉伯帝国——倭马亚王朝、阿拔斯王朝，以及后来瓜分了最初阿拉伯帝国的各个继承帝国——他们以伊斯兰教的名义为自己辩护，而他们征服的人民成为了穆斯林，因此将他们的征服视为真主意志的表达。我的意思是，这难道听起来不是一个合理的论点吗？你知道的，我最近和某个人讨论过这个话题，他们说：“你知道的，帝国总是坏事，它们总是充满压迫，诸如此类。”然后我
you say that before i always think that's very evasive well so the classic example of that is the arab empire um right the empire surely not well so so the arab made that claim on so the arab empire um the emmaids the abbasids and then the the various inheritor empires that um carve up the original arab empire um they justify it in terms of islam and the people that they've conquered become muslim and therefore see their conquest as an expression of god's will i mean i does that not seem a reasonable argument you know i had this argument with somebody somebody recently and they said um you know they empires were always bad they're always oppressive and all the rest of it and i
说——当然，当人们进行这种对话时，他们几乎总是想到18、19和20世纪早期的欧洲殖民帝国，对吧？然后我说：“哦，那奥斯曼帝国是一件非常糟糕的事吗？”当时出现了一种尴尬的沉默，对方不知道该说什么，然后我说了和你刚才一样的话：阿拉伯帝国。你打算争辩说阿拉伯帝国是邪恶的吗？当然，没有人会提出这种争论，我认为不是因为他们害怕，而是因为这是一种不言自明的愚蠢说法。去把一个持续了数个世纪、其绝大多数人民都视为理所当然的事物，以这种简单化的方式一笔抹杀，我认为这简直匪夷所思。
said and of course when people have this conversation they're almost always thinking about european colonial empires of the 18th 19th and early 20th centuries aren't they and i said oh the ottoman empire a really bad thing and there was this sort of embarrassed pause European colonial empires of the 18th 19th and early 20th centuries aren't they and I said oh the Ottoman Empire a really bad thing and there was this sort of embarrassed pause didn't know what to say and then I said exactly what you said the Arab Empire are you going to argue that the Arab Empire was evil and of course nobody will make that argument not because they I think because they're afraid but because it's a self-evidently foolish thing to say, to look at something that lasted centuries, that most of its people took completely for granted,
与此非常相似的是，君士坦丁堡的罗马人（Romaio i），当他们为了保护自己的城市和帝国免受奥斯曼帝国的侵袭而战时，你知道的，他们是以罗马人的身份这样做的。难道他们也是这样看待的吗？是的，但是他们——你知道的，这些人曾在公元前二、一世纪被罗马人非常残酷地征服过。而到了15世纪，他们将自己是罗马人的事实与上帝的意图结合在了一起。所以在那种情况下，我们是谁，竟敢
and to just sort of write it off in this simplistic way, I think is just bizarre. And very similarly, the Romans, the Romeoi of Constantinople, when they're fighting to keep their city and their empire against the Ottomans, you know, they're doing it as Romans. Are they, they see that likewise? Yeah, but they, you know, they, these are people who were conquered very brutally by the Romans back in the second, first century BC. And by the 15th century, they are identifying the fact that they are Roman with God's purpose. So in that, you know, who are we to say
说拜占庭帝国是邪恶的？我的意思是，难道不是基本上这样吗？——牛津大学的历史学家约翰·达尔文在他那本伟大的帝国史著作《帖木儿之后》中就提出了这个观点。他基本上说：帝国是自然的单位。在历史的大部分时间里，帝国一直是人类组织的基本单位。你越强大，越富有，你就越有可能拥有一个帝国。
the Byzantine Empire was evil? I mean, also, isn't it just the case that basically, I mean, John Darwin, a historian at Oxford, makes this point in his book, After Tamerlane, which is a great history of empires. And he basically says empire is the natural unit. For most of history, empire has been a natural unit of human organisation. The more powerful you are, the richer you are, the more likely you are to have an empire.
威尼斯人曾拥有一个帝国。你知道的，葡萄牙曾拥有一个帝国。比利时曾拥有一个帝国。基本上，每当你登上权力之树的顶端时，你就会拥有一个帝国，因为它是影响力、权威以及所有这类事物的表现。一个没有帝国的世界将是一个没有人类的世界。
The Venetians had an empire. You know, Portugal had an empire. Belgium had an empire. Basically, whenever you're at the top of the tree, you have an empire because it's an expression of influence and authority and all of those kinds of things. And a world without empires would be a world without human beings.
我的意思是，这将是我的观点，因为我不认为你能把世界碎片化为那种快乐、和谐、民主的民族国家。事情根本不是那样运作的。嗯，我不太确定我是否同意这一点，因为约翰·达尔文的书《帖木儿之后》基本上聚焦于欧亚大陆。因此，它聚焦于那些
I mean, that would be my view because I don't think you can fragment the world into sort of happy, harmonious, democratic nation states. It just doesn't work that way. Well, I'm not sure I agree with that because the John Darwin book, After Tamerlane, is basically focused on Eurasia. And so it's focused on areas
庞大帝国绝对是常态的地区。所以波斯帝国、奥斯曼帝国、中国帝国，以及在丝绸之路上兴衰交替的各种帝国。但我确实认为西欧是不同的，因为我确实认为——我们之前已经讨论过了——在西欧罗马帝国崩溃之后，一个单一的政权在西欧从未真正成功地长期确立其统治地位。因此，对于欧洲人来说，这种假设是根深蒂固的：正如你所说，这里应该有一大片相互竞争的国家的拼图。
where huge empires absolutely are the norm. So Persian Empire, Ottoman Empire, Chinese Empire, the various empires of the Silk Road that kind of rise and fall. But I do think Western Europe is different because I do think that it's, you know, we already talked about this in the wake of the collapse of the empire, the Roman Empire in the West. A unitary power never really succeeds in establishing itself for a lengthy period of time in in western europe and so for europeans the assumption is kind of hardwired that um as you say that there should be a kind of patchwork of of competing states um and yet and yet they're trying to get i mean the europeans have the the message you get from europe now is
然而——然而他们正试图做到这一点——我的意思是，欧洲人现在从欧洲得到的讯息是：那是通往灾难和世界大战的道路。你知道的，伏思达（Guy Verhofstadt）——那个将自己清晰地视为欧洲统一的加富尔伯爵的欧洲议会比利时籍议员，对我和我而言就是源源不断的快乐源泉——他说：“你知道的，欧洲应该是一个帝国，我们生活在一个充满帝国的世界里，欧盟应该是一个帝国，我们应该抛弃所有这些琐碎的国家分歧。”这就是《罗马条约》和欧洲统一的某种假设，对吧？“越来越紧密的联盟”。所以，让我们建立一个帝国吧。
that's the road to disaster and world war and you know giever hofstadt the um the sort of uh who sees himself clearly as the kind of count cavour of european unification the belgian mep for me the gift that keeps on giving he says you know europe should be an empire we live in a world of empires and the european union should be an empire and we should put aside all these petty national differences. And that is the kind of assumption of the Treaty of Rome and European unification, right? Ever closer union. So let's build an empire.
我认为，欧洲内部促使国家分裂、导致建立欧洲统一的尝试土崩瓦解的过程，与将它们凝聚在一起的冲动一样源远流长。而且从来没有真正产生过某种协同效应。我的意思是，这就是我们现在作为欧洲人所面临的巨大问题：欧洲能否凝聚在一起？你知道的，这是一种新秩序吗？那种碎片化的时代已经过去了吗？但这里的悖论在于，正当欧洲人试图在全球范围内做到这一点时，正如联合国所反映的那样，这背后其实是一种关于人们应该如何组织自身的欧洲假设，而这种假设绝对根植于欧洲的民族国家理念之中，并且是由欧洲殖民主义传播到全世界的。
I think the processes within Europe that encourage states to fissure, attempts to construct European unity to fall apart, are as constant as the impulse to kind of bring them together. And there's never really been a kind of synergy. I mean, so this is the huge question for us now as Europeans is, will the European hold together? You know, is it a kind of new order? Has that age of fragmentation gone? But the paradox is that even as Europeans are trying to do this across the globe as reflected in the United Nations is a European assumption about how people should organize themselves that is absolutely rooted in the European idea of nation states and which was spread around the world by European colonialism
我认为欧洲内部促使国家分裂、导致欧洲统一努力瓦解的过程，与试图将它们凝聚在一起的冲动一样持久。而且从来没有真正形成过某种协同效应。我的意思是，这对我们欧洲人来说是一个巨大的问题：欧洲能否凝聚在一起？你知道，这是一种新秩序吗？那个分裂的时代已经过去了吗？但悖论在于，正当欧洲人试图做到这一点时，正如在联合国所反映的那样，全球范围内存在着一种关于人们应该如何组织自己的欧洲假设，这绝对植根于欧洲的民族国家理念，并通过欧洲的殖民主义传播到世界各地。
so the reason that the Middle East now is divided up into a patchwork of nations and does you know is not an empire basically for the first time since uh since since the achaemenid era the first persian empire is because of european colonialism and the power you know the huge paradox of kind of anti-imperialism in the west is that it's incredibly and irreducibly western it's yeah it's it's this fusion of biblical classical traditions melded together and to decolonize something is basically to make it more western it seems to me that i think that's i think that's a very good point but also i think it may not be that the future belongs to nation states because of course china is effectively an empire.
所以，中东现在之所以被分割成众多国家，并且基本上自阿契美尼德王朝——也就是第一个波斯帝国——以来首次不再是一个帝国，是因为欧洲的殖民主义。你知道，西方反帝国主义最大的悖论在于，它是极其且根本上属于西方的。它融合了《圣经》和古典传统，而将某物去殖民化，基本上就是让它变得更西方。在我看来，我觉得这是一个很好的观点，但我也觉得，未来未必属于民族国家，因为中国实际上就是一个帝国。
The United States, I would argue, is an empire. Russia is an empire. So the idea that we're living in a post-imperial age, I think, is a fantasy. Anyway, we have completely failed to get into the questions. Yes, so choose a question, Dominic. Well, why don't I just go for the first one, which is from Graffitology.
我认为，美国可以说是帝国，俄罗斯也是帝国。所以，我们生活在一个后帝国时代的想法，我认为是一种幻想。无论如何，我们完全没有切入这些问题。是的，那就挑一个问题吧，多米尼克。好吧，为什么我不直接选第一个呢，这个问题来自 Graffitology。
So he's talking about the British Empire, which we haven't really talked about at all. And it's not a podcast about the first one, which is from Grafitology. So he's talking about the British Empire, which we haven't really talked about at all, and it's not a podcast about the British Empire, but I suppose we can do a question or two on it. Grafitology says, on the subject of the British Empire, I'd love to hear your thoughts about how the perception of it has changed
所以他在谈论大英帝国，我们之前几乎没有谈过这个。而且这不是一个关于大英帝国播客，哦不对，这是来自 Grafitology 的问题。所以他在谈论大英帝国，我们之前几乎没有谈过这个，虽然这不是一个关于大英帝国的播客，但我想我们可以回答一两个相关的问题。Grafitology 说：关于大英帝国，我很想听听你们对它的看法是如何改变的……
from a good thing to a bad thing in British culture, whereas many in previous British Empire countries have fond recollections of those times. Do they? Well, I think, I don't know. mean i i my take on this is that people in previous um colonists of the empire uh don't really think about the british empire very much at all because they're too busy getting on with their lives and the people we hear from um are people who are unusually politicized or who are unusually interested in what is now the increasingly distant past.
在英国文化中，它从一件好事变成了一件坏事，而许多前大英帝国国家的人对那个时代却有着美好的回忆。真的是这样吗？嗯，我觉得，我不知道。我的看法是，帝国以前的那些殖民地人民其实根本不太会去想大英帝国的事，因为他们忙着过自己的日子；而我们听到声音的人，都是那些不同寻常地热衷政治的人，或者对现在越来越遥远的过去格外感兴趣的人。
I don't think the British are... If you look at recent polls, we're neither unusually proud nor unusually self-flagellating. It's the Dutch, isn't it? The Dutch are kind of insanely proud of their empire. Yeah. I mean, I always think, you know,
我不认为英国人……如果你看最近的民意调查，我们既不是异常骄傲，也不是异常自我鞭笞。是荷兰人，对吧？荷兰人对他们的帝国有一种疯狂的骄傲。对，我的意思是，我总是觉得……
these polls are a bit ridiculous because i just don't think most people give a damn one way or the other they don't think about it very much there were brilliant surveys done in the mid 20th century so around about the high point of our empire and they would ask people to name colonies or name possessions of the british empire the most common one that you knew people usually in was scotland and i think something like lincolnshire was in the top 10 so that tells you how much people i think ever really cared about the british empire or knew about it so there was a kind of vague incoherent sense that it was a good thing wasn't it kind of lurking yeah i think you see my my
这些民调有点荒谬，因为我觉得大多数人根本不在乎这到底是好是坏，他们不怎么去想这件事。在20世纪中期——也就是我们帝国鼎盛时期左右——曾做过非常精彩的调查，当时他们让人们说出殖民地或大英帝国的领地，最常被说出来的竟然是苏格兰，而且我记得林肯郡似乎也排在前十名。这说明人们以前对大英帝国到底有多关心，或者对它有多了解。所以当时有一种模糊不清、语无伦次的意识，觉得它是一件好事，对吧？就潜藏在那里。是的，我认为你看我的……
take on this right which we should get into in another podcast is that people didn't give a damn about the empire they like being top top nation. They liked status. But whether that status involved a particular colony or control of a given sea lane, I mean, they didn't know what was going on and they couldn't really care less. They just liked the impression of power and prestige. I think that's what has always mattered to European colonialists. And, of course, money.
我对这件事的看法是——我们应该在另一个播客里深入探讨——人们根本不在乎帝国，他们喜欢做顶级大国。他们喜欢地位。但这种地位是否涉及某个特定的殖民地，或是对某个海上航线的控制，我的意思是，他们根本不知道发生了什么，也完全不在乎。他们只是喜欢权力跟声望带来的这种印象。我认为这才是欧洲殖民者一直以来所看重的。当然，还有金钱。
Far more than the sort of... I don't think people ever obsessed about the nitty-gritty of their empires. But I think also running with that, right the way through the period of British imperial expansion and rule, is the sense that British people have that it's wrong. So... Well, there was always argument about it. Always argument, always kind of anxiety about it.
这远比那种……我不认为人们曾经对帝国的那些细枝末节痴迷过。但我认为与此相伴的，贯穿整个英国帝国扩张和统治时期的，还有英国人内心的一种感觉，那就是这是不对的。所以……嗯，关于这一点一直都有争论。总是充满争论，也总是有一种焦虑感。
And I think that, you know, that that is also part of what the British export. So I was reading C.L.R. James's book on cricket beyond the boundary. And he's writing as a Marxist who's very, very anti-imperial. And yet what's manifest is it's an incredibly British book. It's absolutely saturated in English literature and, you know, obsessed with cricket, with everything about it. And reading it now, it's kind of positive about Britain in a way that very few British people today are. And I think it it kind of points to the way in which anti-imperialism what paradoxically was something that was exported by the British as well as as
我认为，这也是英国出口的一部分。所以我当时在读 C·L·R·詹姆斯关于板球的书《超越边界》（Beyond a Boundary）。他写这本书时是一个非常坚决反帝的马克思主义者。然而显而易见的是，这是一本极其英国化的书。它完全浸透在英国文学之中，痴迷于板球以及与之相关的一切。现在读起来，它对英国的赞赏方式，是当今极少数英国人所不具备的。我认为这也指出了这样一种方式：反帝国主义，具有讽刺意味的是，它和帝国主义一样，也是由英国人出口的……
as well as imperialism and even even as someone like Frantz Fanon um you know who's in in a way the kind of the great um the great spokesman for anti-colonialism born in and raised in uh the the french caribbean empire he is saturated in um philosophical assumptions that derive from yeah yeah yeah ho chi minh worked as a chef i believe under lescoffier subject that's a subject for another podcast so let's move on to another question which is on this sort of ground, which is from Tom Shaw. Tom Shaw says,
甚至像弗朗茨·法农（Frantz Fanon）这样的人——你知道，他在某种程度上可以说是反殖民主义的伟大代言人，出生并成长于法属加勒比帝国——他也深深浸润在那些源自……对，对，对，胡志明据说曾在埃斯科菲耶（Escoffier）手下当过厨师，这个话题留给另一个播客吧。所以让我们进入下一个问题，这个问题也属于这方面的范畴，来自汤姆·肖（Tom Shaw）。汤姆·肖说：
our attempts to come to terms with our imperial legacy, much of it traumatic, undermined by our rose-tinted view of ancient empires. The baffling idea, to Tom Shaw anyway, that India was lucky to be colonised by us, surely stems from a place of misplaced gratitude for Roman rule. And then he says, great pod.
我们试图接受我们的帝国遗产（其中许多都是创伤性的），却被我们对古代帝国的玫瑰色滤镜所削弱了。对汤姆·肖来说，印度很幸运能被我们殖民这种荒谬的想法，无疑源于对罗马统治的一种错位的感激之情。然后他说，很棒的播客。
Well, I, you know, to stick to Britain, I think that our attitudes to the Roman Empire, again, are incredibly paradoxical. Because for British people in the 19th and 20th century, who are they identifying with? Are they identifying with the Britons or are they identifying with the Romans? So outside the Houses of Parliament next to Westminster Bridge, you have a statue of Boudicca, whose name means victory, so Victoria. So she's an emblem of the British Queen, summoning up the idea that the Britons are destined to rule and to fight but of course buddhica is is a a rebel against imperial power and uh there's a sense as well that the british identify with the romans and that kind of tortured conflicted sense is i think still very much with us we're kind of conflated buddhica and britannia haven't we so the image of britannia that you used to used to be on the 50p the sort of the the Roman or Greek helmet and the shield and all that sort of stuff.
嗯，我（你知道的），就拿英国来说，我认为我们对罗马帝国的态度同样极其矛盾。因为对于19、20世纪的英国人来说，他们认同的对象是谁？他们认同的是布立吞人（Britons）还是罗马人？所以在威斯敏斯特桥旁议会大厦的外面，有一尊波狄卡（Boudicca，又译布迪卡）的雕像，她的名字意思是胜利，也就是维多利亚（Victoria）。所以她是英国女王的象征，唤起人们这样一种观念：布立吞人注定要统治、要战斗。但当然，波狄卡是对抗帝国力量的叛军，而且人们也有一种感觉，即英国人认同罗马人，这种备受折磨、充满冲突的感觉，我认为至今仍然深深伴随着我们。我们把波狄卡和不列颠尼亚（Britannia）混为一谈了，不是吗？所以你以前在50便士硬币上看到的不列颠尼亚的形象，那种罗马或希腊式的头盔、盾牌以及诸如此类的东西。
In the public mind, I think they're kind of the same. They sort of merge into this sort of Elizabeth I type, you know, this sort of feminine personification of Britain, which is both fighting foreign imperialists and an imperialist in and of itself. Well, but just to follow up on that, I think it's a commentary on the reality of roman imperialism that the first representation of britannia
在公众心目中，我觉得它们基本上是一回事。它们融合成了伊丽莎白一世那种类型的人物，也就是不列颠的那种女性拟人化形象，她既是与外国帝国主义战斗的战士，其本身又是一个帝国主义者。嗯，但接着这一点说，我认为这正是对罗马帝国主义现实的一种讽刺：最早的不列颠尼亚形象……
shows her as a woman being raped by the emperor claudius oh so that doesn't doesn't tend to feature in the coins no i wouldn't go on you choose a question uh well there's one about christianity which i i suspect you don't want me to ask. We'll skip over that one. Here's one from George Ellingham. Do empires that intend to last aspire to become a single nation federal state, i.e. China and the Soviet Union, or is this a more modern nation? Oh, that's a good question.
把她描绘成一个被克劳狄乌斯皇帝强暴的女性。哦，所以这往往不会出现在硬币上。不，我不会这么选。你挑个问题吧。嗯，有一个关于基督教的问题，我猜你不会想让我问。我们跳过那个。这里有一个来自乔治·埃林汉姆（George Ellingham）的问题：那些想要长存的帝国，是渴望变成单一的民族联邦国家（例如中国和苏联），还是更现代的民族国家？哦，这是个好问题。
That is an excellent question. Do they aspire to that? I think probably not at first though you do get so for example with russia you had you've had moments of kind of russification if that's a word and the the sort of tendency was to try and russify provinces let's say the baltic states or Ukraine, and to see them as kind of Russia's little brothers and to eradicate kind of national differences. Though it's interesting with Russia how, you know, Russia is still quite a sort of fragmented country. Politically, you know, if you look at the map, the way it's structured, it sort of follows um old patterns and you have tatarstan and so on kalmaikia and the caucasus i mean the caucasus is a very good example of how you can't just impose
这是一个极好的问题。它们渴望成为那样吗？我猜一开始可能不会，尽管你确实会发现……例如在俄罗斯，你曾经历过某种“俄罗斯化”（如果这是一个词的话）的时期，当时的一种趋势就是试图将各省俄罗斯化，比方说波罗的海国家或乌克兰，把它们视作俄罗斯的小兄弟，并消除民族差异。不过有趣的是，就俄罗斯而言，你知道，俄罗斯仍然是一个相当碎片化的国家。在政治上，如果你看地图它的结构方式，它在某种程度上遵循了……旧的模式，你有鞑靼斯坦等等、卡尔梅克和高加索——我的意思是，高加索就是一个很好的例子，说明你不能只是强加……
a kind of imperial stamp and and turn everybody into little russians but caucasus is mountainous so that's a kind of another that's right you know that that empires tend to reach geographical borders where yes yeah i think that's absolutely right. And let's say China. I mean, China has limits. You know, China can't go on expanding forever. I think the Chinese recognise they had limits. And with the peoples who were on the sort of margins of their empire, the Uyghurs are the obvious newsworthy example,
一种帝国的烙印，然后把所有人都变成小俄罗斯人。但高加索地形多山，所以那是另一种……没错，你知道，帝国往往会到达地理边界，在那些地方……是的，是的，我认为这绝对正确。再说中国。我的意思是，中国是有极限的。你知道，中国不可能永远扩张下去。我认为中国人心知肚明他们是有极限的。至于那些处在他们帝国边缘的民族——维吾尔族就是一个显而易见、备受瞩目的例子——
they aren't, you know, they don't see themselves as Han Chinese. And hence the stories that you get in the media about camps and about indoctrination and all the rest of it. So, yeah, I think, George, empires may have that aspiration, but to realise it is a very different matter. OK, so following that up with a question from Neil Connolly, when do we stop calling it empire and empire?
他们并不……你知道，他们不把自己视为汉族。因此，你在媒体上听到的关于集中营、洗脑以及其他种种事情的报道也就不足为奇了。所以，是的，乔治，帝国可能有这种抱负，但要实现它则是完全不同的另一回事。好了，顺着这个话题，我们来看一个来自尼尔·康利（Neil Connolly）的问题：我们什么时候开始不再把“帝国”称为帝国了？
So that's an interesting... Much of Russia is a result of imperial conquest, yet we happily consider its territory to be part of the state, likewise the Western USA and Northern Ireland. So actually not just the Western USA, the whole of the USA. I mean, the whole of the USA, the whole of America is an imperial project, isn't it? It is, right.
这是一个有趣的问题……俄罗斯的大部分领土都是帝国征服的产物，然而我们却欣然将它的领土视为国家的一部分，美国西部和北爱尔兰也是如此。所以实际上不只是美国西部，整个美国都是。我的意思是，整个美国、整个美洲都是一个帝国项目，对吧？确实是这样。
And I think it's very strange. You know, scholars have written books about American empire and American imperialism. And Americans themselves resist it because, of course, their nation, their sort of founding myth is the sort of Star Wars myth of, you know, plucky rebels fighting off the evil galactic empire, which is us. And so they sort of deny their own imperial nature.
而且我觉得这非常奇怪。你知道，学者们写过关于美洲帝国和美洲帝国主义的书。而美国人自己却对此进行抵制，因为他们的国家，他们那种建国神话，是《星球大战》式的神话——也就是勇敢的叛军奋起反抗邪恶的银河帝国（而那个帝国就是我们）。所以他们某种程度上在否认自己帝国的本质。
But of course, the United States is an empire. It has all the trappings of empire. It has subject peoples, which is to say the Native Americans in their reservations. It has colonies. It has Puerto Rico and it had the Philippines. Has imperial conquest. And it has bases. Stuff taken from Mexico. Stuff taken. Exactly. It's got bases all over the Philippines. Has imperial conquest, stuff taken from Mexico?
但当然，美国是一个帝国。它拥有帝国的一切特征。它有被统治的人民，也就是保留地里的美洲原住民。它有殖民地。它有波多黎各，而且曾经拥有菲律宾。它有帝国征服。它有军事基地。从墨西哥夺取的东西。夺取的东西。没错。它在全世界到处都有基地。它施加影响的方式，如果你是一个公元三世纪左右的罗马战略家，思考着你与波斯人、或与你北部和非洲等地的民族之间的竞争，以及你如何在他们之间纵横捭阖……
Stuff taken, exactly. It's got bases all over the world. It exerts influence in a way that, you know, if you were a Roman strategist in the sort of third century, thinking about your rivalry with the Persians or with the sort of the peoples to your north and in Africa and so on, and the way in which you play those off against each other
还有你的附庸国和你的缓冲区。这就是美国决策者们的思考方式。你知道，这就是他们在西点军校学习的内容。这就是华盛顿特区外交关系委员会以及所有这些机构里的人员所做的事，他们回溯罗马的历史，因为他们内心深处知道，正如以前的那些国家一样，他们也是一个帝国。好了，多米纳尔德（Dominoald），我为你准备了……
and your client states and your buffer zones. And that's how American policymakers think. You know, that's what they study at West Point. That's what the people who are in the Council of Foreign Relations and all these things in Washington, D.C., they look back to Rome because they know that deep down that they are an empire as those previous states were too. OK, Dominoald i've got
一个绝佳的后续问题，那个问题来自克恩·奥尼尔（Kern O'Neill）：是不是可以说，当今的帝国更多是数字化的存在，而不是民族国家式的存在？谷歌、亚马逊、微软，当然还有脸书（Facebook），因为在我们录制这期节目时，脸书正与澳大利亚政府陷入某种“炮舰外交”风格的对峙。你对此有何看法？这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为我们曾经有过商业帝国。我的意思是，东印度公司就是一个典型的例子。是的，还有荷兰。那种由私营公司演变成的帝国。
the perfect follow-up for you that one uh is from kern o'neill um might it be said that the empires of today exist digitally rather than nationally google amazon microsoft um and of course facebook because as we're recording this facebook is in a kind of you know gunboat diplomacy style standoff with the Australian government. What's your take on that? That's a really interesting question because we have had commercial. I mean, the East India Company is a classic example. Yeah, and the Dutch. Of a private, of a company.
对，荷兰东印度公司。所以，这些公司后来变成了帝国。但有趣的是，它们随后被传统帝国的概念所吞并——我本来想说国家帝国，如果这不算自相矛盾的话，但你知道我的意思。是的，嗯……东印度公司基本上是被英国政府接管了，或者至少它的领地是这样的……这种情况会发生吗？我是说在谷歌身上，在数字化方面……这很难说，对吧？我想，那是心灵的帝国。我记得我曾去过硅谷，参观了那些……各大科技巨头园区的各种园区。
Yeah, the Dutch East India Company. So of companies that became empires. But then they were sort of, it's interesting how they were then subsumed within the idea of a kind of traditional i was about to say a national empire if that's not a contradiction in terms but you know what i mean yeah um the the the east india company was basically taken over by the british state or at least its possessions were um will that happen i mean at googler digitally i mean that's very hard to say, isn't it? Empires of the mind, I suppose. I remember I went to Silicon Valley and went on a tour around the kind of various campuses of the
我想那是谷歌。他们有一个巨大无比的、带有谷歌标志的招牌。然后我们转到后面去看了看，结果发现……嗯，后面竟然是一些倒闭公司的标志，它显然是被……是的，它显然是被循环利用了。你知道，你会想象谷歌完全负担得起一块崭新的……负担得起一块崭新的招牌，但它既然这么做了，那一定是有意的，这就有一种踏在帝国覆灭的坟墓上的感觉，这某种程度上非常壮观，或者类似这样。是的……好吧，这里有一个来自卢卡斯·罗斯（Lucas Roth）的问题：生活在……我本来希望你会问卢卡斯·罗斯的问题。生活在帝国里的人们……是的，生活在帝国里的人们，加引号的，是不是比生活在帝国之外的人们过得更好？这就把我们带回到了……
big sites. And I think it was Google. They had a huge, great kind of sign with Google on it. And then we went around and looked around the back and it was um there on the back was some some fallen company and it had obviously yes it had obviously been recycled and you know you imagine google could afford a fresh um could afford a fresh sign but it's so it must have been deliberate a kind of trampling on the grave of the uh of the fall of empire which is kind of magnificent or something yes um okay here's one from lucas roth were people living in i was hoping you were gonna ask lucas roth were people live yeah were people in empire living in empires better off in inverted commas than people living outside the empire that is you know that takes us back to quite a lot of what
我们一直在谈论的很多话题。嗯，这取决于你指的是哪个帝国，对吧？我的意思是，如果你生活在比属刚果，我想生活在那个特定领土的边界之外会更好，因为你可不想因为没有收集到足够的橡胶而被人砍断双手，诸如此类。生活在罗马帝国境内是不是比境外更好？或者生活在波斯帝国境内比境外更好？比方说。我的意思是，我对这个问题的回答可能倾向于“是”……因为我认为帝国为你提供了……如果你是一个……显然，如果你运气不佳，你知道，在帝国统治下日子其实挺难过的；但如果你很幸运，如果你的天赋得到了眷顾，比方说……
we've been talking about well it depends on your empire right i mean if you're living in the belgian congo i would say it's preferable to be living outside the borders of that particular territory because you don't want to have your hands cut off because you haven't collected enough rubber or whatever um were you better off to be in the roman empire than outside it or the persian empire than outside it let's say i mean my answer to that would probably be yes um because I think empire offered you you know if you were I mean obviously if you're unfortunate you know things are pretty rough under empires but if you're fortunate if you're blessed by talent for example um you have opportunities for advancement for travel um for economic prosperity and so on that you probably wouldn't get if you were born in the sort of germanic forests now
你拥有了晋升、旅行、经济繁荣等方面的机会，而这些机会如果你出生在日耳曼森林里的话，大概是得不到的。也许这只是某种罗马中心主义的偏见在说话吧？对，对。你觉得……嗯，我想我们又回到了那个规律：伟大的帝国，那种跨大陆的帝国——中国、罗马等等——达到了它们的自然极限，在这些极限之外，征服的开销和努力基本上就不划算了。所以当罗马人到达莱茵河时，基本上，你知道，德国不值得费劲去征服，征服它不值得付出代价……
maybe that's just right prejudice talking yeah yeah you think well i think again we go that the great empires the kind of transcontinental empires china rome so on reach the natural limits where basically it it stops being worthwhile the the expense and effort of conquering so when the romans reach the rhine basically you know germany's not worth the effort it's not worth the effort of conquering um and then you start to get the situation where actually it's people beyond the empire who want a bit of the wealth. And the role that the various peoples who cross into the empire over the course of the fifth century is much debated. But clearly, I mean, they have a role to play. And they're coming in because they want a bit of it in exactly the same way that the Mongols famously invade and conquer China.
然后你就会开始遇到这样一种情况：实际上是帝国之外的人想要分一杯羹。至于在公元五世纪期间跨越边境进入帝国的各种民族所扮演的角色，人们对此有很多争论。但很显然，我的意思是，他们确实发挥了一定的作用。他们进来是因为他们想分一杯羹，这和蒙古人入侵并征服中国的道理完全一样。
That people outside want what empires have because it's richer. And that sets up a kind of law of empire that you get in Herodotus, that you get in Tacitus, that you get in Ibn Khaldun. Namely, that empire softens people. And it's people outside empires who are tough, who are hardy, who have the virtues that the original imperial peoples had, but have now lost because they've become, you know... That's the sort of Spartan self-image, right?
因为帝国之外的人想要帝国拥有的东西，因为帝国更富裕。这就形成了一种帝国的规律，你在希罗多德的书里能看到，在塔西陀的书里能看到，在伊本·赫勒敦的书里也能看到。也就是说，帝国会使人变得软弱。而保持坚韧、强悍、具备最初的帝国人民所拥有却因变得……而丧失的美德的，恰恰是帝国之外的人。这就是那种斯巴达式的自我形象，对吧？
Yes. Spartans versus the Persians or something. Yes, so the Greeks, the Romans, the Arabs of the Imperial Age all have a kind of sense of themselves as a martial people who are better qualified for rule than the soft peoples that they conquer. But in due course, the empires that they establish, you know, they become kind of silken and soft in turn and then become prey to the barbarians beyond the border and this is seen by all these writers writing very different periods
对。斯巴达人对阵波斯人或类似的情形。是的，所以希腊人、罗马人、帝国时代的阿拉伯人，都有一种自我认知，觉得自己是尚武的民族，比他们征服的那些软弱的人更有资格进行统治。但随着时间的推移，他们建立的帝国（你知道）反过来也会变得骄奢淫逸、软弱无力，然后成为边境之外的蛮族的猎物。这一点，在所有这些生活在截然不同时期的作家笔下……
as a kind of you know the rule of empire and i would i would not be surprised i don't know enough about china to know whether the same thing is identified in china i would guess it it probably is um but it's exactly what americans say now, that they've become distracted, self-indulgent. You know, they're sunk in a kind of malaise of introspection and quarrelling and that they've lost the, you know, the Spartan Republican virtues of the founding fathers and all this sort of stuff or of the greatest generation. So that that trope is still there in the way that Americans talk about their empire. OK, I think we've barely scratched the surface. We could talk about this for hours and hours, but it's a policy, must be a policy of this podcast not to outstay our welcome. So just one last question for you, Dominic, from David Nicholson. Is there historical veracity to the claim that all empires day in the sun lasts around 200 years and i ask
都被视为一种帝国的铁律。如果有人告诉我中国也有同样的规律，我也不会感到惊讶，虽然我对中国了解不够深，不知道中国是否也有这种现象，但我猜大概也是如此……这正是美国人现在所说的，他们变得心猿意马、自我放纵。你知道，他们陷入了一种内省和争吵的泥沼，他们已经失去了国父们或“最伟大的一代”（Greatest Generation）那种斯巴达式的共和美德，诸如此类。所以这种陈词滥调在今天美国人谈论他们的帝国时依然存在。好了，我觉得我们只是触及了皮毛。我们可以就此讨论几个小时，但本播客的原则之一，一定是不速客留步、适可而止。所以，多米尼克，大卫·尼科尔森（David Nicholson）还有一个最后的问题：那种“所有帝国的阳光灿烂的日子都维持在大约200年”的说法，有历史真实性吗？我问这个问题……
that not just because the question in itself is interesting but because of the the idea that there might be kind of almost the equivalent of biological laws that govern empires um can we you know can we say that empires do have a natural limit what do you think um i would say no and i don't think that 200 years works at all and i don't think there is a limit so china we had a whole podcast on china and china is the standing rebuke to that now i know there is this discussion about how is china has it always been one thing or has it been a succession of things on the same space but i think that it had the fact that it has inhabited the same space suggests continuity and suggests that you can keep it up.
不仅是因为问题本身很有趣，还因为可能存在几乎等同于支配帝国的生物学规律的这种想法……我们能（你知道）说帝国确实有自然的极限吗？你怎么看？嗯，我会说“没有”。我不认为“200年”这个说法在任何意义上成立，我也不认为存在这种极限。所以中国——我们曾专门做过一期关于中国的播客——中国就是对这种说法的有力反驳。现在我知道有一种讨论：中国究竟一直是一个实体，还是在同一空间内政权的更迭？但我认为，它一直占据着同一空间这一事实，就暗示了某种连续性，并表明你可以将它维持下去。
I mean, if you take some of the empires that people often forget about, we mentioned the Ottoman Empire or its predecessor, the Eastern Roman Empire, which we now call the Byzantine Empire. We tell the story of Rome and we say, well, then Rome fell in 476. And then basically there was a successor state in the east but no one cares about that and it kind of went away and but that lasted a thousand years and it was a remarkably resilient and successful state attacked by lots of different predators and would-be conquerors and it lasted a very long time the Ottoman Empire lasted longer than you know the
我的意思是，如果你看看人们经常遗忘的一些帝国——我们提到过奥斯曼帝国，或者是它的前身东罗马帝国（我们现在称之为拜占庭帝国）。我们讲述罗马的故事时会说，罗马在476年灭亡了，然后东方基本上出现了一个继承国，但没人关心那个国家，它差不多就这样消失了——然而那个帝国持续了一千年，它是一个异常顽强且成功的国家，经受了许多不同掠夺者和野心征服者的攻击，并且存活了很长时间。奥斯曼帝国持续的时间比（你知道的）……
British Empire the French Empire or whatever so I think empires can last for centuries. And I don't think there is actually a... The example of China, or indeed Russia, suggests that there isn't necessarily always this kind of sense of entropy. You don't have to fall apart. There is no biological... There's a point at which you can't expand. I think that's certainly true. Although maybe that law about expansion only applied in a pre-digital age because of transport and communications and so on
大英帝国、法兰西帝国或任何帝国都要长。所以我觉得帝国可以持续几个世纪。而且我认为实际上并不存在……中国或俄罗斯的例子表明，并不一定总是存在这种熵增的趋势。你并不非得四分五裂。没有哪种生物学规律……当然，确实存在一个你无法继续扩张的点。我认为这绝对是真的。尽管也许关于扩张的那个规律只适用于前数字时代，因为当时受制于交通和通讯等等……
maybe you know the chance of a really big empire um is there in the 21st or 22nd century what do you think i don't i don't know what the future holds um i i know i know and i i say that because i you're right that i don't know whether um the opportunities presented by technology will facilitate the emergence of of new ways of structuring societies and different hierarchies and things like that. I mean, we haven't really talked about the role that technology plays in the emergence of empires. And that may be, you know, something for a future podcast. I mean, he's a good...
也许（你知道）在21世纪或22世纪，出现一个真正超级大国的机会是存在的，你觉得呢？我不知道，我不知道未来会怎样……我知道，我知道，我之所以这么说，是因为你说得对，我不知道技术带来的机遇是否会促进新社会结构方式、不同等级制度等事物的出现。我的意思是，我们还没有真正讨论过技术在帝国崛起中所起的作用。这或许（你知道）会成为未来播客的一个主题。我的意思是，这是一个很好的……
I don't know. I mean, and looking at China and the incredible skill with which it's utilising technology to, you know, entrench its rule over the kind of peripheral regions. I don't see the Uyghurs breaking free of Chinese imperial rule any time soon. So I wouldn't be able to answer that, really. Here's a forward-looking thought, though though we talked about europe earlier and about the failure of of a single state to dominate the european sort of peninsula um after the fall of the western roman empire surely the chance now you know in the next 100 years or so i mean the dream of of of european enthusiasts is that there will be a single state. The European Union will become this empire in all but name,
我不知道。我的意思是，看看中国以及它利用技术以巩固其对周边地区统治的惊人技巧，我看不出维吾尔族人在短期内能摆脱中国帝国的统治而获得自由。所以我也无法真正回答这个问题。不过，这里有一个面向未来的想法：虽然我们之前谈到了欧洲，谈到了西罗马帝国灭亡后单一国家未能主导欧洲半岛的失败，但难道现在——在未来的100年左右里——欧洲狂热者们的梦想不会实现吗，即出现一个单一的国家？欧盟将成为一个名副其实的帝国，
crossing national boundaries in a way that simply would not have been conceivable or possible in the 17th or 18th or 19th centuries. So to me, the idea that the age of empires is behind us or that empires indeed have this sort of inbuilt limit or there are places that are naturally resistant to empires i don't really buy any of that well it's a cheery notion which to uh on which depends if you like empires on which to end and um i think also you know what we've
以一种在17、18或19世纪绝对不可想象或不可能实现的方式跨越国界。所以对我来说，“帝国时代已经过去”或者“帝国确实有这种内在极限”或者“有些地方天然抗拒帝国”这些想法，我其实都不买账。好吧，这是一个令人振奋的想法，如果你喜欢帝国的话，这也是一个完美的收尾。而且……我想我们也从……
realized from from this discussion is that there's fruit for large numbers of podcasts we've done about we've done about four percent of the questions which is yes we have so many many apologies there um but i think this is a subject definitely to come back to perhaps with a slightly narrower focus all right so i have a very nicely written um conclusion here by the producer which i want to read because it conjures up to me a very nice image. The Empire has fallen, Tom Holland has been chased out by angry locals and the podcast has been returned to its rightful ruler, me. We're back on Thursday with historian and TV presenter Susie Lipscomb as we are delving into the dark world of witches and witchcraft. Until then, thanks for
这次讨论中意识到，这里有大量可做播客的素材。我们大概完成了所有问题中的百分之四，也就是……是的，我们确实完成了这么点。所以非常非常抱歉……但我觉得这绝对是一个值得再次探讨的主题，也许可以稍微缩小一点焦点。好吧，所以制作人在这里为我写了一段非常漂亮的结语，我想把它读出来，因为它在我的脑海中唤起了一个非常美好的画面。帝国已经倒塌，汤姆·霍兰被愤怒的当地人赶了出去，播客已经回到了它合法的统治者——也就是我——的手中。我们将在周四回归，与历史学家兼电视主持人苏西·利普斯科姆（Susie Lipscomb）一起深入探讨女巫和巫术的黑暗世界。在此之前，感谢收听。
listening. See you next time. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下期再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。